JP SOUCHAK: If you've been
working in web development,
you might ask yourself, how can
I separate myself from the pack
and get recognized?
Introducing the Mobile Web
Specialist Certification
by Google, an achievement
available to those
who can demonstrate the skills
of an advanced level mobile web
developer.
The first step on
your journey is
determining if you're
ready to take the exam.
Start by learning
what the exam covers.
Review the skills that
you'll need to demonstrate
when taking the exam.
Next, decide whether
you need training
or if you're ready
to take the exam.
You can reference
our study guide,
and training is
available online.
When you're ready, sign
up and take the exam.
As part of the sign up,
you'll pay an exam fee.
If you live in India,
you'll pay 6,500 rupees.
If you live outside of
India, you'll pay $99 US.
After you've signed
up and paid the fee,
you'll receive a
voucher that you
can use to schedule the exam.
The exam's a timed,
performance-based assessment
in which you'll
write code to solve
challenges and demonstrate
your skills in mobile web
development.
You'll have four hours to
finish, after which you'll
submit the exam and respond
to a set of exit interview
questions.
If after grading
you are successful,
you'll receive a digital
badge from Google
and join our community of
Google Certified Mobile Web
Specialists.
Once you are certified,
you can share your badge
on your resume,
LinkedIn, G+, Twitter,
and in your email signature.
Ready to start your journey?